it happened again
another package bomb exploded in Texas
today a state on high alert this one set
off at a FedEx facility near San Antonio
it all started on March 2nd a 39 year
old father killed by a bomb mailed to
his house in Austin 10 days later two
similar attacks nearby killing another
and injuring two the fourth bomb went
off Sunday this one on the side of the
road in a residential neighborhood and
rigged with a tripwire two people hurt
and early this morning a fifth explosion
at a FedEx facility one worker was
injured an intense manhunt is currently
underway before the killer or killers
strike again here's President Trump
bombings in Austin a terrible local
state and federal of working
hand-in-hand to get to the bottom of it
this is obviously a very very sick
individual or maybe individuals these
are sick people and we will get to the
bottom of it
joining us now from Austin Texas Casey
Siegel who's been closely following this
unsolved mystery Casey
hey Kimberly good to see you and beyond
with all of you guys you know things
took a very different turn today when
the these unexploded devices were found
at FedEx distribution locations at least
one we have confirmed for sure that
means now instead of someone just
placing these on someone's doorstep like
we previously saw or putting it in a
residential neighborhood with a tripwire
which is what we saw here on Sunday this
is where it gets different because now
we're talking about someone physically
putting a package into the distribution
system and so they go to giant places
like this one back here multiple FedEx
locations across central Texas being
investigated and we want to kind of
break them down for you okay because
there is a lot of moving parts and a lot
of conflicting information frankly
that's out there this is a big location
right here in Austin and it is on the
outskirts of Austin Bergstrom
International Airport now officials say
that a suspicious package was found here
this morning and it has closed the whole
thing down Spencer if you could my
photographer go on into the mobile
command unit back there because we
should point out there was no explosion
here just a suspicious packages all
they'll say but see that mobile command
unit back there
Austin police a very big presence here
in addition to ATF and FBI agents so
we've got that here now the second
location that is in shirts which is near
San Antonio a shirts distribution center
and that is where the package exploded
this morning when it was going down a
conveyor belts you imagine those big
Amazon distribution sites in the United
States Post Office all of the mail and
packages are being sorted every which
way on those belts it was going down one
of those belts apparently when it went
off and fortunately no one was right
next to it so no serious injuries there
was some initial talk about a second
package that was found at that location
it did not detonate but that it may be
contained explosive materials police
have since walked that back and they've
said that now only one package was found
at that location the one that went off
then we've got a third spot and that is
in Sunset Valley which is only two miles
or so from Sunday night's crime scene
and officials in Sunset Valley have
roped off a FedEx store there and the
thought is that the package that
exploded at that distribution center
down near San Antonio that it might have
originated from that location again only
two miles from Sunday's scene so it is a
little confusing you have multiple
locations multiple victims and a whole
lot of concern because again this is a
city on alert some 420 calls of
suspicious packages came into 911 just
in the last 24 hours according to Austin
Police and you can imagine that is
straining the resources guys all right
Casey we have a couple questions we're
gonna take it around the table okay
Casey what are that what's the advice to
the citizens there because I mean 420
packages I mean if you get a that many
calls it's gonna take a while for the
police to get there right but they are
wanting to make sure that they dot all
of their i's and cross their T's which
is why governor Abbott's the governor of
Texas and and others have diverted a lot
of law enforcement resources here there
are more than 500 federal agents alone
500 federal agents ATF FBI boots on the
ground here and that is not including
all of the Austin police officers and
the bomb squads that have been brought
in from Houston PD and the rest so
they're flooding it with resources so
they can follow up on every single one
of these tips but the primary message
being since the public is to remain
vigilant and if you see something say
something
I was talking about this yesterday in
our reporting you know we're used to
doing that at say the airport or at a
big public event the Superbowl you know
game or something however not so much
when you're in a residential
neighborhood or if you're in a
McDonald's or something let's say so
they're asking people if you see
something do not touch it and call
police so they can come follow up on it
Dana
thank you okay one has a question for
you Casey Casey what about copycats do
we know is this the work of one person
or multiple people is there anything
like that that is giving us some hints
as to what's going on here and I have a
follow-up after you finish yeah one
that's a good question because there is
concern always with copycat crimes and
that's one of the reasons police say
they're being very guarded with the
information they release that's why they
said there are only similarities with
the explosive devices that have gone off
so far the similarities they won't go
into a great detail with because if they
release too much information as you know
say something perhaps only the bomber or
the bombers would know themselves they
don't want to put that out there into
the public so that people a don't copy
the crime and B they don't want to
jeopardize their investigation so right
now they don't believe that this is a
copycat situation it could be the work
of one person or more they say frankly
they simply don't
1kc just a quick follow-up you know
initially the two people who died were
black men and then there was the
suspicion on the part of the
Congressional Black Caucus that you know
they should be identified as a terrorist
act and then you had the n-double-a-cp
saying to the black community but then
the last two people injured were white
so where does that stand now well it
kind of threw the whole you know
targeting instance or motive potentially
that was being discussed kind of out the
window is how I gathered it from law
enforcement yesterday because you're
right
the first several bombings the first
three that started on March second one
man was killed and then ten days later
two people killed in a single blast
these were all packages that were left
on a porch they didn't go through a
distribution center they weren't mailed
they were just dropped off on the porch
overnight and then the people opened
them removed then and caused the
explosion
the victims were African American or
Latino and these were in East Austin
traditionally known as a lower-income
area if you will so that's where that
that theory came out that they might
have been targeting specific groups of
people a hate crime something like that
but with the tripwire being put on the
device on Sunday police say that that
meant it was designed to hurt anybody
who had discovered it so not a specific
person so that kind of took the weight
out of that argument a little bit all
right Casey thank you
okay we'll take it run sample Greg gun
these your thoughts on this we've had it
laid out in terms of the facts and what
the police and authorities know so far
obviously reluctant in the middle of an
investigation to give out some of the
characteristics or signature elements of
the bombs and how they compare or
they're dissimilar in some respects
clearly we don't know much from that so
these events just show once again how an
individual or a group of individuals can
command an audience and it's as
contagious as it is alluring it could be
copycats it could be one person media
coverage focuses on it so heavily that
it's just irresistible to continue the
challenge in this world
to somehow like fight this numerical
significance where one person a shooter
or a bomber or a terrorist can affect
thousands of people or in fact millions
because all of the different network
coverage so he's already affected the
world and it's a it will be seen as the
success meanwhile what the real the real
lesson from all this is that you know
evil deeds succeed with proper planning
as long as you plan ahead we still don't
know anything about Vegas we know
nothing and the reason why we don't know
anything is because he planned for two
years that's why we have to plan you
know a half a plan cannot go up against
the full plan clearly this is a planned
event and we have to learn we have to
plan against these planners he who plans
wins alright kadena well it's just
thinking about you know I know that as
of yesterday they had 500 federal law
enforcement officers on the ground in
order to help that probably has doubled
and it's not just happening in Austin
where you have to be vigilant because
copycats if you have something on
national media copycats could happen
anywhere in the country and so the
resources that are required in order to
deal with things like this to hopefully
disrupt plans if you can but if not then
deal with the aftermath
I mean local law enforcement and state
governments are having a big problem on
their hands because they got a lot of
resources a lot of things that they need
to spend money on and there's not enough
money to go around and so the most
important thing one is economic growth
with thankfully we have right now but
planning ahead because these types of
things are going to continue it's not
just localized anymore it's not just
going to be in the Austin
american-statesman it's going to be all
over the world Jesse well I'll speculate
because there's really nothing else to
talk about it's not Isis in my opinion
because it's not spectacular and there's
no video and they haven't claimed credit
for claims yea so far the racial angle
was interesting because at the beginning
that was three minorities and it was two
white men I just don't like how it
becomes so racialized right at the
beginning but I think they're still
leaving that open but let's just put
that aside to me it looks like a serial
killer that doesn't want to get his
hands dirty someone that enjoys toying
with law enforcement someone that enjoys
the gamesman
ship of it all and someone that I think
is going to get caught pretty soon
because there's video cameras all over
these distribution centers whenever you
drop off a package there's going to be
surveillance footage it's obviously
someone sophisticated because they have
the trip wire technology so it's not an
idiot but it's not someone you know CIA
it's not that high level it's obviously
someone that gets their materials from a
local store from what we're hearing from
the Senators maybe an anarchist someone
that just likes death and destruction
it's really hard to tell it's just sad
because Texas and Florida at this point
have suffered so greatly in the past
year whether it's natural disasters or
these shootings or these bombings you
know it just takes a special type of
citizen in these two states to reckon
with it and in Texas like they always do
is doing a very good job yes also I
think what's interesting is they have an
unexploded device now they're going to
be able to study which is gonna be
significant because it's almost
impossible to not leave some kind of
trace of DNA or forensics that could be
a clue and then you have all the pieces
the parts you know intact they can trace
back the you know origination for where
all of them were purchased or where they
came from and look to see any
similarities there and then there's just
the construction of it we can actually
show the detail of a particular group of
it's a terrorist or a sole actor etc one
years comments well I think that what we
know is that there have been a variety
of delivery methods used on these bumps
so it's not all the same bomb and then
today I was watching Danish show at 2:00
and she had on an expert who said that
in fact the detonation caps are
different and very difficult to obtain
and so if you go and find the source
which is what Kimberly was just
suggesting of those that nation caps or
detonation caps that were lost that's
going to be a big clue what could be
doing that on purpose to obfuscate so
they wouldn't be able to determine that
it was one single or sole actor to make
it appear that it is multiple
individuals yeah but it could be this
thing I don't know that's what we don't
know but it could be that one guy has
somehow obtained these detonation caps
and the second point here is that you
have I think a lot of people who are at
the moment
alarmed and uptight and I think that
that can't be overstated how nervous
people are in Austin and what's going on
now why us and why at this moment and
it's not clear okay well it seems so far
the kind of the tone and tenor that
they're looking at like a serial bomber
who's being very clever to not reveal
himself not put any manifesto out so
that avoiding any attempts to
communicate with law enforcement and FBI